I have a ton of questions about this
movie but I like throwing individual
questions at the beginning um so I'll
start with you uh you're involved in
some show that's popular on Netflix I
think it's called a Wednesday yeah maybe
something like that and I'm just curious
how much are you looking forward to
filming season 2 and do you know when
you're actually filming season 2 no idea
when but I am very excited to get back
into it I can't wait to see my friends
and jump back into it it's very strange
cuz I've not done a roll and then come
back to do it it's kind of weird cuz you
feel like you finished it but going back
into it you got to remember what you did
dust it off I know oh uh an individual
question for you did you ever think you
were going to wear the Electra suit
again I don't know what you're talking
about so what could you mean I'm
hypothetically thinking you could be in
a dead cool sequel hypothetically not
that I'm aware of okay I'll avoid I'll
move on so uh jumping into why I get to
talk to you guys
uh I am very curious when you're this
has to be an unusual thing uh getting
ready to do a body swap you've done it
before but what is it actually like like
the few days or the before you step on
set getting ready to do something like
this where you're trying to mimic
someone else but maybe you haven't
worked with them yet you don't really
know them it's as weird as you can
imagine it's truly it's like full actor
mode I mean Emma as a person is kind of
a cat and I'm a golden retriever or a
Labrador puppy so just just swapping
that energy is one thing but Jess my
character is a boss she's a she's a
badass she runs a team of people she's
responsible she's a grown-up she's a mom
she got d d du and she is like a
teenager who is like there's so much
pressure on me you don't understand
anything I am a soccer star everyone's
relying on me the whole school is
looking at me and you don't even care so
um we were we played it as puppies we
played it as follow the leader we
mirrored smelling each other's feet we
did it all rolling on the floor yep
we're very comfortable together yes I
might be one of the few that noticed but
what I was excited about was noticing
the band Weezer is in the movie I Am I
am a big fan so I really want to know
what it was like in the third act you
get to perform with them and I want to
know like how nervous are you to step on
stage with an actual rock band that is
famous and really good really nervous
yeah and it was pretty clear the second
started that they're the real deal and
we are not I can't sing so that just
immediately made me nervous but Ed had
us covered he made us look good yeah
he's like I said for like I said to him
years ago like he you know release
albums like he's a talented musician yes
for real yeah you know um so definitely
you see the schedule you know what
you're going to be shooting what is the
day you have circled in terms of I
cannot wait to film this or I am
dreading filming this outside of the
Weezer sequence I couldn't wait to do
the party dance sequence the bust a move
and honestly it was every bit as much
fun as I ever could have hoped Beth
nicely cografted it and she came in and
just did something that we could all
handle right away even Ed and we just it
just the F it just grew to be more and
more fun as the night went on I couldn't
wait to do the car chase that was very
fun I've never done one of those before
so getting on the high it's legit it
doesn't matter if it's a comedy you're
still doing a car chase on that note I
really sincerely hope this a huge hit
for you guys and good luck with the rest
of your speed dating thank you thank you
very
much